big news out of Washington today this
hearing in the House Judiciary Committee
take a listen to one of the exchanges
from this afternoon I am the deputy
turned general United States okay I'm
not the person doing the redacted I'm
responsible for responding to your
concerns as I have so your statement
that I'm personally keeping information
from you trying to conceal information
here at the boss mr. roses diary that's
correct
and my job is to make sure that we
respond to your concerns we have sir but
your use of this to attack me provided
you son wrong I bar on your thoughts on
this hearing and what came out of it
well that was the roughest exchange of
the day between Republican Jim Jordan
and Rod Rosenstein and which Jordan and
a number of others have complained about
redactions that don't seem to make much
sense or we're not necessary and
documents handed over and Rosenstein
essentially said hey don't don't look at
me important to remember today that the
house actually passed with 226 votes a
non-binding but sense of the house
resolution saying that the Justice
Department has been withholding
information and that should they should
turn it over immediately
and while Bob Goodlatte the chairman of
the Judiciary Committee did say that the
Justice Department has has been
performing better on that score lately
there is still a lot that they simply
haven't turned over
we heard Jason that Peter struck in his
testimony had DOJ lawyer there and he
didn't really answer all of the
questions according to people in the
room the president tweeting out today
Peter struck worked as the leader of the
rigged witch-hunt for a long period of
time he got it started and was only
fired because the gig was up but
remember he took his orders from Comey
and McCabe and they took their orders
from you know who Muller Comey
bestfriends Jason there is a frustration
not only on Capitol Hill but you can
hear it around the country your thoughts
about all this well Congress is a
co-equal branch of government brett with
oversight responsibilities and some
people at justice seem very slow to
understand that and Congress's role here
and and and when you just tell the
congressman about the volumes of
documents you sent them knowing that
that's not really what's relevant
it's these word actions that are
relevant are you turning over the dot
I've been asked for and they're not and
there's a very much of frustration among
Republicans that rod Rosen Stein has not
rained in this investigation this Mullen
investigation
and kept Muller on track and made sure
that he's doing what he was asked to do
and not going astray on fishing
expedition so yes there is a lot of
frustration here mostly the other big
news is this summit upcoming in Helsinki
on July 16th between President Trump and
Russian President Vladimir Putin here's
the president it's gonna be great the
world has to start getting along I think
we'll be talking about Syria I think
we'll be talking about Ukraine I think
we'll be talking about I recommend
everyone to refrain from using the words
break through meetings and so on I
suggest a pragmatic and realistic
attitude towards these meetings
certainly russian-american relations
have been ready for a number of meetings
on various levels long time ago because
the bilateral agenda has been demanding
it
Alessa there's some people that really
have a problem with the meeting at all
this summit but this really set people
off and president tweeting Russia
continues to say they had nothing to do
with meddling in our election where is
the DNC server why didn't say D James
Comey and now the disgraced FBI agent
taken closely examine it why isn't
Hillary Russia being looked at so many
questions so much corruption thoughts
III don't know if the president is
trying to do what he did with North
Korea which was a photo op that did
nothing to benefit the United States and
certainly benefited the leader of North
Korea many Americans feel and I think
that's what's going to happen sadly with
Russia and with his meeting with who and
Brett because again another photo-op you
have the president siding with Putin who
says he didn't metal you have his own
Department of Homeland Security and
other departments and other
investigations that have showed contrary
with the president is tweeting out also
the appearance that he seems to be
endorsing Putin's take and reasoning for
annexing Crimea and our allies in the
Western world are trying to isolate not
embrace Putin and I don't think that the
president should be meeting with Putin
and quite frankly again what are we
going in
and what are we getting out of this
meeting we shouldn't be accommodating
Putin that should be the other way
around
all right baron well I I think the
president takes any opportunity to make
his defense in the Trump Russia affair
but I think on the other side from what
Lesley was saying is they could Trump
and Putin could talk about all the very
tough things that the president has done
as far as Russia is concerned the
sending arms to Ukraine striking
militarily Russia's client in Syria
developing new missiles developing
low-yield nuclear weapons pushing NATO
to spend more money there are a lot of
policy things that Donald Trump has done
in addition to new sanctions more than
the Obama administration put on that
haven't been done before all right panel
thank you very much busy day